they are the founders of xpt extreme
performance training and his book life
rudder heart body soul and life beyond
the ocean is available where all books
are sold great to have here together on
the Rich Eisen show they've been on
separately but together as a couple
Laird Hamilton and Gabrielle Reece good
to see you nice to see you what's going
on your lives what's going on everything
you know I think like everybody we're
trying to raise our daughters well
actually ones in the real world and this
one has a job College can you believe it
what is she doing she's reading lidar
which is like radar
I know hold on the side and okay the
mailman something okay so you know we
tell our kids you can actually use your
brain to make a living what do you like
to the Florida State University
Gabrielle hi kids wanna be different so
they just figured how can I be different
than my parents all do okay like laser
mapping yeah so we're doing the kids and
see if they can try to be you know it's
a crazy time you know you've got small
children just and when your kids tell
yours are a little bit younger you don't
understand mm-hmm we don't understand
like what they have to navigate you know
coming up is very it is truly different
than what we're dealing with so we're
trying to learn and grow and so we have
the middle daughters a little more she's
hitting tennis balls right now like a
like a crazy person she can purchase
playing eight hours a day out of her own
choice right you know and then and then
the youngest one she's she runs the show
pretty much my five-year-old daughter
runs the entire show I'm an only child
so this is all new here we go
Laird I don't usually say this to
somebody before I've truly gotten a
chance to get into a conversation but
I've been in your pool yeah if you're
aware about your dog I brought Hudson
yes you came when I wasn't there I got
out of it gets a little stranger with
your wife told you the story Chris
because I nearly lost my life in that
pool because you put a vest of magnets
the hell's in this vest palette yeah
we've evolved since then now we do it
with weights that you can set down
gently and get away from the beginning
days it was vest there's like just tread
and you're like okay yeah yes before the
extreme performance training started
honing a little bit I got the Game of
Thrones treatment yes we all went
through two blurbs like just do this and
we were like okay so this was what you
have now evolved what started would you
have now evolved you and your in your
performance training right is that I got
in the pool with a vest you're no G wait
and go tread water and it was by the way
excellent core exercise you're not gonna
lie no fear there's a little bit also
yes a lot of fear and also uh some
cardio like I didn't know that I was
actually sweating actually before you
were working out you were getting cardio
you can say to people that you you know
you did it the hard way because now
what's so great about it is now we have
all this stuff you can do and it's can
be really ballistic easy on the joints
we've made it so whether you are afraid
of the water not good in the water not a
swimmer or dynamic mm-hmm we have
something for everybody
yeah but XPT itself is just the pool is
one aspect of it so it's really breathe
move and recover it's really the
philosophy behind that training and it
has to do with mobility breath work it
speaks to longevity I mean it's not and
we can subject anybody to it it's not
just you know what is he even subjected
to by the way I was a boss in the
recovery part after that day I mean you
know you see people they train
especially athletes and you go okay and
your recovery day and they go yeah I do
nothing and learn is a great example of
somebody who has had obviously a
longevity and performance and and it's
like no you can actively recover you can
do things to participate in recovery and
the breathing is a big thing because
it's also I always say it's free and you
can do it everywhere and it's the
essence of life what's the most
important thing to performance as well
so breath is it's all about breath right
at the end of the day we give it very
little importance I mean I can take top
athletes and I run
breathing routine and they really aren't
great at breathing and they can they're
not great you know cart of
cardiovascular sure I think they are
they think they're there because they
can run around all day it doesn't mean
that you really have optimum breath work
can you drop me a name on I would never
do that on who has come on
hyperventilating me I'm not gonna come
on but I see he's a big part of what we
do - that's a great that's a great tool
need and I say yeah you come over again
for the ice yeah nobody loves nobody's
like I love the ice dad you know it it's
you got a it's the the usual you know
McCain before gain and all of that Laird
Hamilton Gabrielle Reece here on the
Richard show that's the extreme
performance training over 30 years of
putting this together and I was part of
the putting it together xpt live.com
life rider heart body soul and life
beyond the ocean written by you Laird
and Julian Bora what is this what's this
book about why did you decide to write
this book I mean you know I I think the
reason why we want to write it is
because we felt like there were some
things that we could share with people
then that they could benefit from and
it's I kind of got a little bit of
pressure to write it actually to be
honest that's a completely different
topic
but no and so there's some philosophy
stuff in there and there's some the nice
thing about the book is that it's it's I
mean I'm learning from it in the process
of writing the book there's a lot of
research on Island Islanders and and
sociology around Islanders and how it
living on Island influences you and
being connected yeah you know tribal
living the notion of sharing not owning
you know I think it's I can say as an
outside person who's inside that the
great thing is is that being in the
ocean and being in nature I think has
taught Laird a lot of
really important lessons that he can
communicate succinctly and it's about
everyday things and it's so it's not
about surfing and it's not about like
being you know extreme it's really a
simplistic and sophisticated way I think
of how Laird looks at things pretty
clearly sometimes that's pretty neat
it's available where all books are sold
right now how did you two guys meet I
was hosting a television show which one
was that it was called the extremists it
was one that I did after MTV Sports and
Laird was a guest and you know after
first communication yeah it sound like
Laird was that nice to me in the
beginning and you know she I mean come
on a television host pretty attractive
girl I was like and he didn't know I hit
sports that was the other thing he's
like oh it's a gun for hire some blonde
girl and then after he was much nicer
and I think we lived together eight days
later we did yeah hold on a second
we'd walk through it so you interviewed
Laird for this show yeah and by the way
it was a show by the way that she was
doing hmm the activities of the other
participants in each version and usually
it was hang glide skydive yeah you know
or a drag motorbikes like you do here
activities and and it was a show that
really came out of MTV Sports the
original yeah okay so I was listen most
of my guests liked your show I had maybe
two or three women over the years all
you know athletes and they were all guys
so it wasn't like hey let's hook up it's
a dating you know service yes I was
there to work and you're being
professional professional okay and then
that all went out the window when I met
Laird literally that was in 1995 and so
interview over and then know that were
exchanged no no no don't I'm sorry I
mean no I'm just kidding no brought me
to play volleyball with Laird was part
of a crew called strap they serve
created this tow-in surfing back in
those days yes and when it was flat they
played beach volleyball who knew and so
they asked me like two three days later
hey will you come and play and so I
shooting a horse polo segment I said
sure they brought me over one of the
wives and then I need a ride back to my
hotel and Larry was there he's the only
one I knew function took you 23 years to
realize that you just don't know me
right now there's no that's amazing
that's very for but you know what listen
you know this because you're in a
marriage that with somebody that you
love and respect very much to you I know
well that's true but you start to
realize the grass isn't greener and if
you're with somebody that you really
like and you're attracted to and you
respect and you can sort of get through
stuff because people have asked us Oh
have you ever gone through things and
I'm like well once in the 30 of our
marriage and once in the 11th year of
our marriage but not that I remember
it's of course it's hard it's not
perfect because I feel like we are
really lucky and there might be this
idea that it's oh it's so perfect and I
never want to sell that what I want to
sell is we have a lot of things going
for us and we work at it and and also
when you're with somebody that you
really can be with you you got to take
care of that you got a you got a lot of
times too you you realize that that the
thought of not being together is you
just not that's not something that you
ever want to experience you're like I
don't ever not want to be with you so
being with you I'm gonna do whatever I
take whatever I need to do to be able to
be with you yeah or and just that's why
we trained so we can make I mean Larry
train so you can still surf but I train
really so I can try to be sort of a
nicer human nicer you'd see work things
out through your your exercise on my own
yeah yeah under water my wife's the same
way as well so are you guys competitive
with each other no that doesn't mean no
people ask do you compete with Laird I'm
like why would I do that
I can't win that race what are you crazy
well there's no way only in volleyball
maybe yours
but I don't play volleyball any more
than that and that ended with me riding
in the back of the truck all the time in
my face yeah yeah it was like oh now
we're competing in the one thing that I
might have a fighting chance yes
I mean Laird is I can say this he's a
very talented athlete yes so it's I'm
not gonna compete with him it's like me
trying to compete with her you know with
intelligence I don't even try okay I
just oh yeah you're smart mental dude oh
no like can you fall for me I don't need
to be smarter than her okay
like it's okay when was the last time
Laird Hamilton Gabrielle Reece here on
the rich ask you a few more minutes left
yeah what was the last time Laird you
ate a pizza well I had a cauliflower
yeah a piece of a cauliflower pizza yeah
but does that count that would be pretty
good I'm not alert I'm talking about a
real like New York yeah like cheese yeah
yeah so you saw me like the room
cauliflower no let's not trying oh yeah
veggie it up like a real deal okay I
would I would eat one like I'm like no
no I'm just saying I'm capable of eating
him I just I don't remember actually
when the last time I ate but I would
like it like it wouldn't I'm not that's
an air of some sort no no okay I'm gonna
be able to you know you can't listen I I
don't think it's good to have a system
that is so fragile
if you throw a slice of pizza in there
yeah yeah it wreaks havoc I think you
need to be able to sure if you gotta go
somewhere and eat something and it's
like I'm Sam bumpy diesel truck it just
you little water in the fuel might make
a few little misfires but you're still
going you're still you know we're still
rolling we don't we don't want we don't
need high tuned
you know whoops the fuel ratio is wrong
boom we blew the motor I don't want I
don't
I scream that's not about ice cream
that's actually the one of the worst
things you can eat nomination is you
have to you you wanna but listen if you
eat real real stuff if you make real ice
cream which I mean with Barry
raw dairy cow no Chernykh variant well
honey it would be that would be that's
why ice cream is ice cream because in
its in its original state it was the but
not credible I mean now when you're it's
anything we feel like we're in denying
ourselves you've had ice no right no yes
I think he realizes what you have to
realize once you don't do it for a long
period of time you actually don't really
miss it will you create what you feed
you crave what you feed that's the rule
so you know that if you're consuming yes
if you're consuming a lot of sugar yeah
anything sweet you're gonna because
people go oh you have such willpower I
go actually I'm just not craving I crave
other eye cream like you know I'll at
the end of dinner I'll be like you know
what I didn't have enough good fat in
that meal right I just macadamia nuts
I'll be in the corner and I might throw
it on some raw yogurt or something and
be like macadamia nuts and Roy yogurt
and that's in crank we're missing out is
that it how do I say this I think you're
I do think you're missing out a little
bit okay so what I would like to be as
healthy is but it's not about being
healthy like I have a knee replacement
Laird has his hip he's surfing big waves
were you know listen it's I think for
both of us it's like how you feel yeah I
know yeah all I do is just sit on my ass
all the time it strike fortunately that
means even you even have to be like how
long do you think it would take if I
stiff I stayed off of sugar how long
would it take me to not have that to not
to not go crazy three months less than
that yeah but you know did you know her
a good thing right time did I give up
sugar you give me more sexy time she's
probably listening right now and I'm you
know listen it's not about this is what
I tell people it's not that you can't
eat it of course you can you just you
just don't okay well then you have to
replace it you just do you have to say
and don't look at what you can't see me
you can't focus on what you can they
is more what you can sure what you can
life rider get the book right now go to
x PT live.com for more about extreme
performance training with Laird Hamilton
and Gabby Reece great guys say the best
you really are and so concludes the rare
instance of me conducting interview as
easily the third least attractive person
on the set the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience